SPEAKER 1: Let's take a look
at a Cloudstate Kotlin example
that uses the Lightbend
Cloudstate service to run
this on the cloud.
And you can find the
source code on GitHub,
jamesward,
cloudstate-sample-fraud.
OK, first let's take
a look at the code.
So with Cloudstate,
we use protobufs
to model the messages
that we're going to send
and then the RPC operations
that will be performed.
So we have a transaction with
a time stamp, amount, location,
and description.
And then we have
a user transaction
that associates that with
a Cloudstate entity key
which allows us to do the
partitioning of the messages.
And that also gives
us the ability
to scale this thing up and
down horizontally based
on what's happening
to the messages
as they're being partitioned.
OK, and then we have a way to
add a user transaction and Git
transactions.
Let's take a look at
the activity entity.
And this is where the logic
for handling those messages
happens.
So we've got an
EventSourcedEntity.
And then you can see
there's a constructor
argument with the user ID
which is our partitioning key.
So that's how we're able
to partition this data.
In this class, we
have our transactions,
which is our mutable list.
And so whenever we get
transaction messages coming in,
then we're going to be able
to add them to this list
so that we have our accumulated
state here in this entity.
Then we have a command handler
for addTransaction which
takes that userTransaction.
And then we also get a
CommandContext with there.
And then we can have our
logic for detecting fraud
on a transaction.
So whenever a new
transaction comes in,
we're going to use the past
data and the new transaction
to calculate the velocity.
And so there's obviously
lots of different ways
that we would compute whether
or not the transaction is
potentially fraudulent.
For this simple example,
I'm just using velocity.
And if the user's velocity
goes over a max velocity,
then we're going to say
that there's possible fraud.
And in this case,
we're just going
to put to that to the console.
But then, once we have
detected the potential fraud,
we are going to emit a message
which says, OK, we've done
our handling of this message.
And then that event
handler will trigger.
This will go on to an event log,
which is persisted in Spanner,
in Google Cloud Spanner.
OK, so that's the bulk
of the entity processing.
I've got a little class that
just starts up the server.
And then I've got
a simulator class
that is going to simulate
some transactions.
So let's go over
and run this now.
I already have
this up and running
on Google Cloud via the
Lightbend Cloudstate service.
But let's go to start
up the simulator.
And what this will do is start
adding a bunch of transactions
to this transaction log.
And what we'll be able to
do once this starts emitting
those messages, we'll be able to
see the messages that are being
emitted here in the console.
And then we'll go over
to Google Cloud Logging
to actually see if we
get a potential fraud.
So here we go.
We're now feeding a bunch of
transactions into that system.
We've got multiple users.
So we're doing partitioning
of the data for that entity.
Now, here in the Logs
Viewer in Google Cloud,
now we can see the
server messages
from my entity that's running
up on Google Cloud and Lightbend
Cloudstate.
So let's go try to
jump to now and see.
There we go.
OK.
So it looks like we just
got a possible fraud alert.
And we can see the
user ID, the merchant,
the amount, when it
happened, and then
the Google Map linked to
where that transaction was.
And if we let this
continue running,
we probably will see some more
potential fraud alerts coming
in as that simulator runs.
So you can see we're
feeding in tons of messages.
They're partitioned
based on user ID.
So you get the ability
to auto-scale the service
up and down.
And that's great for
something like this,
where the amount of
transactions that are coming in
is going to fluctuate
throughout the day,
with probably more transactions
happening in the morning
and evening, I would
guess, and less at night.
And so, great.
We can scale our service
automatically based on that.
There is a container image
that I built and deployed
which contains my entity code.
OK, so that's the quick
example of Cloudstate
running on the Lightbend
Cloudstate service.